story from the hill we we've talked
about it quite a bit but I do want to
bring it up in another context because
we're we're we're talking right now
about what life was like in the Trump
era from we're talking you know 2017
into the beginning of 2021 and right now
we keep seeing these stories pop up this
one's from from last from a month ago of
course that Trump is getting a big boost
with younger voters we're now seeing
another story that genz groups are
panicking and trying to buy up domains
and that support Trump to trick Trump
supporting young people into not
supporting him that's how panicked the
Democrats are and I saw this video today
of a micro apartment in New York City
it's uh you know 60 70 square feet it
has no bathroom it has no kitchen it has
a sink and it is a like 5 1/2 foot by 10
foot Corridor with a
door and I think young people are
starting to understand it when New York
City offers up free housing for illegal
immigrants free healthcare for illegal
immigrants and you a young person
entering the workforce entering
adulthood can't AFF for department and
can't afford Healthcare you start to
wonder what it is the Democrats are
doing and why they are doing it to you
and when Donald Trump was President
things were a whole lot better the
economy was booming Jim Kramer for all
of his failed predictions said the best
numbers of Our Lives pertaining to
unemployment economic growth Etc now
under Joe Biden it's been misery young
people are are excited about living in
pods they've got these in San Francisco
you can live in this big room with like
what is it 3x3 pods and you can climb
into your designated tube which is you
know each podt is like four feet you
know uh square like like it's like a
twins siiz bed basically not even are
you serious have you seen these tubes I
mean like approximately it's not fully
they cannot fit a twin siiz bed you
think these these pods where you go into
a big room and it's 4et tall 4T wide and
10 ft deep you can lay down on an air
mattress in that thing if you're lucky
that's how small they are and they're
advertising these are the Cubbies you
can live in you can live in this is what
young people have to look forward to so
it's not surprising to me that many of
them joke all day and night on social
media they have memes about killing
themselves because they're like haha
what's the point of
living I think one of the big reasons
many of us trting to vote for Trump is
because they can see the writing on the
wall they understand Biden is bad he
will make life hard for you Trump is an
open door with light at the end of the
tunnel it's the Mig crisis man and this
idea that sometimes your leader needs to
be cruel perceivably cruel to those out
there so that you and here can prosper
and like sorry at some point like
there's they're always going to make
more people so there's always going to
be more of them out there and I need to
protect my Society i' I've for for ages
thought differently that we could
protect everybody but the reality is
that's why we build walls these these
young voters are are inside this big
mansion that is the United States
they don't have a bedroom they're not
getting any food and they're asking why
is it that we are here giving our money
and working in this place and what are
the Democrats doing opening the door and
letting strange people come in and eat
all the food young people can see that
and take the jobs that that young people
need I think it's about Economic
Opportunity what's the point of going to
college racking up a debt to do so and
then when you get out of college there
are no jobs available M but your student
loans you can't go bankrupt on your
student loans and they're issuing them
forever and ever and ever I mean I think
Economic Opportunity is ultimately going
to change young voters uh from left
leaning you know everyone says that when
you're young or a Democrat and when
you're old you're conservative I was
never a Democrat uh and I think part of
it is the life that people want to leave
is not sustain sustainable under Biden I
mean even if you did want to live in a
city and you know live in the box and do
whatever you know you can't and I think
more and more young people are starting
to see that and saying actually I want
to own land actually I don't want to be
dependent on anyone else actually the
things that I think will will will
sustain me long term line up with a
different uh group of people than are
traditionally pushed on
me yes yeah it's a big cultural shift
that's what I like about the youngest
generation which is like they are this
weird mix of super hopeless people but
then some of them are extremely
motivated to be different we'll see
these waves of young people who are
saying I don't I don't want these things
I want to live differently and I I have
always credit it a lot to um like the
emergence of homeschooling as a dominant
force in America I think that people
being more invested in their education
and challenging sort of status quo
teaching uh has really ignited a a
powerful energy among these young voters
Who coming down the pike um but to a
certain extent they have to be met with
some positive reinforcement and that's
why a trump presidency is so interesting
right now because if you could give them
the chance to have economic Prosperity
they would really cement the culture
they're drifting towards I mean Also
let's just be honest Trump is the more
punk rock candidate that they have to
choose from and even if you're if like
if their attitude really was that they
believe Trump is the
apocalypse but they're making memes all
day and night about burning everything
down and killing themselves then they'd
also be voting for Trump too so it's
just there's nothing Joe Biden has to
offer Donald Trump is the guy who tell
who gives the middle finger to the to
the Press mocks the system and he's got
that youthful exuberance so in terms of
wanting to just screw the system over
it's strong
Trump's the anti-establishment it's also
his I know his friends a lot of his
friends and family and like people they
seem genuinely interested in in
technology I haven't been pinged by the
Biden industry to be like yo what's the
solution here the solution is graphine
and hydrogen we can alter our fuel
system so that we're using hydrogen fuel
in addition to oil carbon based fuel I'm
not having this increase our GDP by 10
times I'm not I'm not having this okay
you're supposed to be promoting graphine
now you're switching to hydrogen fuel
they come it's a it's a part and parcel
package have you heard of graphine
before yes yeah this shit's dude
this is going to be the 21st century
Building Material we're going to be
pumping this out of Rice
University they figured out how to hit
carbon trash with a laser or it's
actually with electricity they'll take
any carbon they'll run a 7,000 degree
current through it turn it into black
powder he desperately wants you to tell
Trump to embrace griffy that's why he's
saying this it's it's a solution it like
it's a material solution and it'll
alleviate like the the sector of the
copper industry that we relying on and
the let's let's let's let's bring us
into practical terms steel what do you
are you are you working directly with
the Trump campaign uh not in a formal
capacity but I'm certainly helping
Donald Trump I think he's the peace and
prosperity candidate I mean I agree I
mean those are the two your two crucial
issues behind immigration we are loping
closer and closer to a World War uh both
in the Russia Ukraine in situation and
in the Middle East Donald Trump could
solve both of those issues relatively
quickly but in in in domestically we've
got the immigration problem and we're
wasting money in Ukraine which affects
us domestically but what do you see
Trump doing in terms of manufacturing
and in terms of uh lower skill labor for
American citizens drill baby drill we
got to go back to to the fact that
there's enough Black Gold there's enough
coal there enough natural gas under
under our own feet to fuel the country
for a hundred years we're back to having
to beg the Venezuelans or the Russians
or others uh for for fuel this makes no
sense at all every president my lifetime
has promised us energy Entre
Independence and none of them delivered
Donald Trump delivered it is the
Keystone to a booming economy it's the
first thing he has to do first thing he
will do yeah can I ask how do you think
Trump is going to handle uh criticisms
he has about covid and when when Co
first you know hit us we didn't know
what was going on there were the initial
lockdowns I think this is something that
a lot of you know never trumpers or
Democrats or even moderates have
questions about uh it seemed like at one
time this was something that he was I'm
going to jump in real quick here because
we had this conversation when Laura
lummer and lucer Kowski were on the show
in uh in Iowa and so now you've got
these just like I don't know winging
sycophants on social media
misrepresenting what I said and so you
have Laura lumer blaming Ronda Santa
saying he he locked everything down it
was really bad you have Lukowski saying
Donald Trump locked everything down it
was really bad and my point
is everyone in the beginning of this
everyone got it wrong Republicans at the
start of covid were advocating wearing
masks and fouchi said not to and then
fouchy flip-flopped and all of a sudden
Republicans were saying don't wear masks
Donald Trump said 15 days to slow the
spread Donald Trump uh uh pushed
operation warp speed personally I look
back and I'm like yeah and Ronda Sanz
was also for mandates and lockdowns too
I don't see the point in having this
Trump is bad no Ron is bad no Trump is
bad back and forth over and over again
to try and adjudicate something happened
four years ago between two guys who did
relatively similar things or in
different ways Trump wasn't a governor
he didn't have control over the states
Ronda santz believed a lot of the same
garbage everyone else did and what
people did was they took this clip to
try to imply that I'm somehow saying
fouchi should not go to prison I think I
think fouchi is directly responsible and
he should go to jail I should I think he
should be criminally charged and
investigated of course but it's it's in
my opinion to attack Donald Trump or
Ronda santis when we look back four
years later we're like oh now that we
understand the origins and now we have
the evidence and now we realize who is
right and who is wrong and who's who's
responsible it's like oh well you know
now we go back and argue that Trump
should have done something different
well you should have but what did
anybody know at the time do you think
this is kind of how the Trump campaign
is responding to
these I I study polls as part of what I
do and even though we all feel strongly
about it when you stack it up next to
immigration and War and the economy it's
not moving that many voters I mean Trump
he relied on the doctors he's not a
doctor yeah he relied on the doctors
that's how I felt about this argument
for a long time that I mean we still get
it from the Democrats that abortion is
going to be the big issue of 2024 and it
just doesn't seem to be especially at
least in the primary season among
conservative voters uh maybe in a
general when you have to face up against
maybe moderates it'll be different but
there are so many things that they bring
forward saying well this is a potential
weakness you know this is this is a a
dent in the chain mail kind of thing and
it seems like no one can actually find
the thing that is irritating voters in a
way that would would uh impede the Trump
campaign I think the covid talking
points of trump are a cope for people
who just don't like Trump and are
looking for a reason to justify why they
wouldn't vote for him I'm concerned
about his staffing issues with you know
the dude with the big mustache that got
us in yeah John Bolton wanted to take
over Iran um and he F and Bolton is just
out some of these horrendous Staffing
decisions that Don made and then the the
fouchy thing just giving he didn't give
him Authority but he basically stood
behind him and nodded while fouchy ran
the show he would do that with some
other technocrat in the future like the
CEO of Google he's like I'm not a social
media guy so I'm going to let the social
media guy run like yo the doctor should
be relying on the president to make the
right decision after their advice is
given not the other way around well
that's quite literally what happened the
other way it was the other way around
Trump was relying on fouchy to make the
right call and basically he like
whatever you say is going to be a yes so
good luck go for it well we don't know
that's absolute that's what it looked
like we know that he had Burks and
fouchy up on stage and it was uh uh you
know in with them all the time and it
was a mistake in hind sight and there
are people who are like I always knew
exactly what was going to happen be ass
dude so many of these uh right-wing
pundits were were screaming buy masks
buy masks now I had people mailing me
masks early on at the start of this
thing when it was March and Donald
Donald Trump said 15 days slow the
spread and we understand these things
were scrubs I just think when you look
at how good things were cons especially
considering the weights they stripped on
his ankles what I hear from you know
some of these individuals who are like I
won't vote for Trump because of what he
did on Co I'm like no new Wars spare me
your libertarian winging when you're
like my justification for why I won't
vote for Trump is some arbitrary thing
about mistakes that were made even
though he's the first president in our
lifetimes to not start a war and to
actually set a timeline to bring our
troops back and to negotiate with these
these countries like North Korea and to
try and get our troops out of Syria
setting a deadline for Afghanistan was
fantastic the Abraham Accords all of
these things were tremendous
achievements and then you're like but
because he wasn't so uh you know because
he made bad decisions at a time when you
know nobody knew exactly what was going
on I won't vote for him now and I'm like
dude if if everything he did with Co it
was it was a lot of mistakes were made I
totally get that fair point Fair
criticism but the idea that that is
justification for why you would not vote
for him now with Biden here or
potentially Michelle Obama when you know
they're going to massively expand
foreign war Ukraine now the largest
recipient of US foreign aid and young
people can't afford Apartments but
they're smuggling humans in giving them
Healthcare giving them houses and then I
hear these people go but Trump made a
bad call on Co I'm like yeah well okay
dude no one knew it was going at the
time we can rag on it now but there's
such a tremendous Gap in what Trump
represents coming to this country if you
vote for him now versus what the
Democrats will do to this country if you
don't and that's what frustrates me it's
an excuse of people who will make an
argument every single day Trump was
right about this he was right about this
he was right about this he was right
about this okay will you vote for him
well because of Dr fouchy no get out of
here dude that's a lie that's Trump
derangement syndrome thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net